all right Gwendolyn yes Gwendolyn and
where are you from where'd you grow up
I'm from the San Francisco Bay Area uh
East Bay and your family growing up
how would you describe them
they're good I have an older sister
who's two years old older and we're very
close and my parents uh they're together
they've been married for 32 years and
they they grew up in a generation that
like didn't really believe in mental
health but the fact that you know and
they themselves have never suffered from
depression or mental illness but the
fact that like they caught on so quickly
to what was going on and we were just
like the biggest Advocates like I'm I'm
very grateful for them so depression
came into your life early
very early yes I think that
um
as a child I was like
very melancholic I'd say
um you know everybody has like their
mood base level which is like your
neutral feeling when you wake up in the
morning
um
and unaffected and then when you get
happy your moot goes up so your regular
mood when you're happy it goes up and
when you're sad it goes down so like
you're typically in a certain range and
I think even like at a young age looking
back I think I was just like one rung
below so I could get happy but like if
my mood dropped for whatever reason it
was
it was more intense I'd say more
visceral but that it wasn't an issue
until
I want to say like the early stages of
puberty like 9 to 11 maybe
um
and then so a regular person's mood is
here mine was here and then all of a
sudden like pretty quickly it dropped
like it just plummeted and I don't I
don't remember if it felt very fast or
if it was gradual but you were how old I
was about 10 or 11 10 or 11. yes there
wasn't anything going your parents
weren't divorcing nothing like that was
going on nope nope it's a brain
chemistry thing you think
if one thousand percent is and that was
really that was very hard because it was
in typically in talk therapy I did like
a decade of talk therapy and it was very
much like trying to pinpoint the thing
in your life that is causing you
distress and trying to overcome it and
my problem was I just could not I didn't
have anything to talk about because it I
could feel like something was wrong in
my brain like I remember saying just
like I feel like my brain is eating
itself like it's so dark and cloudy and
it felt very very physical like there's
only so much that talking can do how
dark would your thoughts get as a 10 or
11 year old
um
I it was it it didn't start off that bad
it was very much like just waking up low
mood low energy
and then around like
12 or 13 I realized like oh this is
going to be every single day just like
living with depression and when you have
such a low and uh mood and low energy
it's just hard to make it to the end of
each day
and so I was like I don't think I can go
on like this much longer and I became
very obsessed with like death and trying
to escape were there certain things that
would trigger it
like things like school homework things
like that yeah just
yeah just my mood was Opera Opera so low
that
I could have dropped a pencil
I would just spiral and be like well
this is proof that I can't do anything
right that something's wrong with me
just absolutely spiraling because I was
at such a low level and if a little
thing set me off it would I would just
spiral
and your parents must have been
concerned I
um when I think I was like 12 when I
finally went to my mom
and I was crying because I was just like
I feel like I can never ever get happy
my I could have won the lottery and my
mood would just reach what a neutral
person's feeling was I could never get
over that just because my brain I guess
this is my hypothesis um but my brain
just could not produce the endorphins
and so I just never felt happy
and eventually I just like started
crying and I told my mom I was like I
just feel like I cannot get happy no
matter what I do and
she was of course she was taken aback At
first she was very very surprised and
then she was like you need to you need
to you should have let me know
um
she saved my life so many times she um
she said like from now on we're a team
if your mood ever drops this low you
need to let me know and she and then
that's when um she suggested that I
start going to therapy so I think I
started at 12. and the frustrating thing
with
family members friends who are depressed
is common sense
doesn't really work you can't say like
you have nothing to be depressed about
and it's not that bad what none of that
works exactly it was it was literally
like nothing outside of myself it was I
was the problem and my my brain was the
problem and it was such a I I remember
the like the thoughts associated with
the feeling but I don't remember the
feeling itself but it felt I remember
thinking like it feels like there is a
black hole in my head and like I feel
empty on the inside
is there anything that you can point to
that might be a cause of it or is it
just genetic I genuinely think that I
just lost the genetic Lottery like it
was probably a rule of the dice and
I wish I knew I wish I knew but
uh with extended family
um there anyone else in your family that
had a similar problem
not that I know my mom she had anxiety
so she had a panic attacks when and she
was on medication for that but it was
very manageable but that's the only
thing I can think of
I I don't know
yeah
you saw therapists I'm sure you saw
doctors yes I went through four
different therapists and I was I started
I think when I was 12.
and the whole thing was very scary
because I had also developed anxiety as
well and just
and like being a teenager all or like a
preteen already you feel awkward and
uncomfortable and now you're in a room
with like an adult having to talk about
your feelings and so that was just hard
to overcome and also
I couldn't articulate I didn't have the
vocabulary at the time to really explain
what was how exactly it felt just
because I was so young and then also it
was just like trying to figure out the
stressor in my life and like I could
complain about math class for hours but
that isn't gonna fix the way that I felt
and you
you went through High School
I did I um I graduated two years early
because I
um
I tested out like in California there's
the thing called the high school
proficiency exam and it's like basically
a GED but if you're younger and so I did
that so I only had two years in high
school and then I started Community
College at 16. and like I very much
liked Community College and I
I love academics and um it was very
satisfying and I loved like the classes
that I had and the passion that teachers
had for their work and
so it should have it should have been
fine because I was enjoying what I was
doing as much as I could but I still
felt exactly the same way
and when did you start getting
you see you seem great right now you
don't seem like you're depressed I'm so
good I'm so good I so when did things
start to get better for you December
2019 I I had tried
Medicaid I uh when I went in for therapy
around 12 or 13 they uh they referred me
to a psychiatrist and so I started my
long journey with trying medications and
started with Prozac and then I probably
took like
seven ssris and then I tried Wellbutrin
which is in I think it's like an ndri or
an nrdi but it's different tried that
that was the only negative experience I
had with medication
um just made me angry but so I tried
that and then they were they were
running out of ssris to prescribe me so
they were like maybe we should try
treating you for bipolar disorder and I
had never experienced Mania but
they um so I tried a bunch of medic like
mood stabilizers and anti-convulsants
and then
um I was put on Lexapro around like age
17 and that was good I used the term
Good Very Loosely in the sense that it
wasn't bad
it was it maintained by low mood so I
didn't have those
drops so I woke I kind of slept walk
through a couple years of my life
because I was kind of a
zombie didn't really care if I lived or
died but then
when I was 18 I did have like a mental
breakdown
um
and
I would there I think there are a couple
factors as to why but I think it was
mostly I transferred to University at
this point and I was doing research on
campus and there was just no one on
campus and I was in the middle of
nowhere so I was very isolated and like
alone with my bad thoughts and then
um my doctor I didn't mention this but I
had been misdiagnosed with OCD just
because like there's a couple weird
things that I do that they thought was
OCD and I don't have it but um
he was like great you know you I earned
the term high functioning depressed
person I hate that term so much because
it's like I look fine to everybody else
and I'm suffering so much on the inside
but at least like you look like a
productive member of society so he was
like you're doing fine let's take you
off of the Lexapro and try to treat the
OCD that didn't exist and I don't know
if you've ever been through uh
antidepressant withdrawal but it's
brutal and so that just combined with
the isolation I just like woke up like
scream crying every single day crying
uncontrollably and I couldn't think
clearly
and that was really hard because like
because my depression had caused such a
Negative self-image that I thought to
myself like
okay I'm not I'm not pretty I'm not
popular I'm not funny but I'm a little
good at school and that's like the one
thing I had what is the most difficult
part of being a depressed young person
and having everyone around you telling
you you have nothing to be depressed
about yeah the doctors are taking wild
stabs in the dark at different
medications what's the most difficult
part for you it was the feeling of just
being stuck and and it's like the one
time that I had the motivation to try
something new because I was so
comfortably uncomfortable for so long
that I was like okay I can
keep living day to day I guess and not
enjoy my existence and here I am like
actively begging to get better and it
was
it was just just the feeling of being
stuck in depression it's like you
already feel stuck with your brain and
now everyone else is telling you like
this is it and
awful feeling awful feeling
but the therapist I was like I don't
know what to I don't know what to do
anymore I can't get over this hump
and I told him um what my doctor had
said and he was like switch
psychiatrists right now you know what's
best for you and so I did and my first
consultation with the new psychiatrist
she looked at the list of drugs I had
been on the list of therapists
everything I tried and then within one
session I got a referral for TMS
and that was covered by Insurance except
for the copay so I'm very very fortunate
that like my insurance was good enough
and I was financially stable to cover
the copay and
that's like such a privilege but I'm
extremely grateful for that because it
saved my life there's no question
there's no doubt in my life in my mind
that it saved my life did you see the
effects quickly yes so you sit in a
chair uh for 20 to 30 minutes a day and
they were like okay you have depression
anxiety they mark on a little cap where
they think they should shock you
um
and it's not I didn't go under
um it feels at first it feels very
uncomfortable like a hammer uh but it
was more like a tapping if you got used
to it and Hammer to what my head so it
felt that sounds horrible no it was more
discomfort than anything it was it was
not that bad and they start at a low
voltage so you get used to it
um it is painful or it's not it's not
it's just uncomfortable and then you get
used to it pretty quickly and So within
within two weeks my anxiety like
disappeared completely and I was like
making eye contact with people and like
chatting up the technicians and everyone
was like who is this person so that was
really fun your personality changed one
thousand percent one thousand percent I
would not recognize myself four years
ago yeah four years but um the
depression went as well
um I started I started to like
getting out of bed was easier each day
and then within like two or three weeks
I did experience a big dip and it fell
exactly the same way that I had been
feeling and I got really scared because
I was like I've come this far and now
it's not working but my doctor uh was
like dips aren't uncommon in the
beginning and I was supposed to have 36
sessions and he was like we're just
gonna add an extra 10 to get you over
the dip so I started in October and
December was like when I started to feel
happiness for the first time which was
so so crazy and then in January was when
I finished and
and yeah and so this is an ongoing thing
or you just did it for that period of
time and you're done I did it for one
session excuse me um the 36 sessions
that year and typically you're typically
your depression might come back and
you'll go in for like another 36 or 46
sessions but it hasn't come back oh I do
want to mention that I was on Lexapro
wall doing TMS and so
I but I felt like I didn't need it
but I kept
taking it just because I was scared my
depression was going to return my I did
have anxiety like a year and a half
later but I think it might have been
related to the pandemic
which would make a lot of sense so I
upped my dosage but I knew that I I knew
that I didn't eat it and I kept trying
to taper off so it wasn't until this may
that I that I uh stopped taking
antidepressants and I feel this as still
happy it's literally it was literally
like I had lived my whole life
in black and white and like
I I can see in color and the happiness
that I get from smiles and laughter come
very easily to you now yes it's so
special like I'll listen to a song and I
feel like so much happiness and I feel
like I could experience like one percent
of the ex I'm so sorry
but I felt like I could experience like
one percent of the extent of happiness
and not so easily I can just feel 100
and it's
I'm so so grateful I'm very grateful
how old do you know I'm 23 23. and I
turned 23 in July and life is very
different for you now yes life's not
easy
you know but but and like the first time
I got sad I was very scared because I
was like oh my goodness my depression
has come back and I realized that normal
people bounce back from sadness and it's
actually temporary so I you know I do
feel sad and so basically this is what's
a TM transcranial magnetic stimulation
TMs in it and TMS stimulates a certain
part of your brain that will activate
these areas that are not
the theory is that it's like the part of
the brain that isn't producing
endorphins it wakes it up and like I had
uh I had never gotten like the Endorphin
release from exercise and that's how I
knew because the first time I and
everyone says that depressed people
should exercise it'll fix it
and I did I regularly exercised just
because like it helped with my sleep but
I never ever got the benefit and then
afterwards I I get so just like insanely
happy from exercise because that part of
the brain is not working
wow
what a wonderful treatment you found
yeah I'm
I'm very grateful
and how has it impacted your life to not
have this depression and anxiety I want
to be alive I know that for a fact I
I was in a very very dark place I
genuinely like did not believe that I
would make it to adulthood there was no
doubt in my mind I would have succeeded
killing myself by now but
that's not a concern anymore obviously
no as a teenager
as a teenager yeah I I just very quickly
I was like I just don't think life is
for me because I can't get happy and
this isn't a life worth living
what was your darkest point
I
I don't really want to talk about that
because it's okay no I don't know you
don't have to
you can imagine
yeah and I regret it very much
I absolutely regret it but I was young
and depressed and
what advice would you give to people who
are going through depression
I think that advocacy and finding people
who will advocate for you which is so
it's a very privileged thing to say to
have like find a support system but
if my mom didn't do the research and if
the doctor told me not to switch
psychiatrists like it literally took a
village to have people to advocate for
me because I just did not have the
ability to do so myself and so I'm so
thankful for the great for the people
around me
it's sad to think that there are people
who probably have gone
their entire lives into old age
and had the same problem yeah I've never
treated it effectively yeah and there's
still there are still new things coming
out like ascetamine has been approved
which is like ketamine tree trials and
then psilocybin trials are going on in
Oregon and so they're all there are
alternatives and it's really sad just to
see that
it's not one it's obviously like one
shoe doesn't fit all but it's sad that
you at least need to try different
things in the fact that so many doctors
are so medication and talk therapy is
the only way when that doesn't even
scratch the surface of what's going on
for like most people
so interesting
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of this
I know what to say
um the best oh my goodness this wise
woman once told me that all we have is
each other
and
I think about like every I'm just so
grateful that my parents understood what
was going on and for the doctors that
had have dedicated their lives to
treating depression and it's
I'm grateful for everyone in my life and
I think all we have is each other and I
wish that I can be the same kind of
advocate for other people that I had in
my own life it must be such a different
experience to go through life you have a
beautiful smile and it comes so easily
and your your laughter and just your joy
and everything is just so
wonderful to see in a young person and
it's like to have that when probably you
didn't four years ago is it's got to
change everything
black and white it was from black and
white to color it was really like that's
the only thing I can think of it was
like same color for the first time
oh
all right Gwendolyn thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you so much
for having I hope this helps a lot of
people I mean too
the only reason I'm doing it
thank you very much